♪
- ♪ GET READY TO GO
♪ GET READY TO GO
- SO SAGE, BRO,
YOU GOTTA TALK TO US.
WE HAVE
SO MANY QUESTIONS, BRO.
WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE?
- IT IS VERY WARM IN HERE,
AND I LIKE IT.
SO WHAT'S YOUR PLAN,
GENTLEMEN?
- BASICALLY,
P90X, CROSSFIT.
I SHAVE MY SHOULDERS.
AND I JUST BOUGHT
A TONGUE SCRAPER.
- CHICKS DON'T DO THAT.
- SO WHAT DO THEN,
THEY VERY MUCH GO FOR?
MINTS INSIDE
OF NECKLACES, BRO?
both: OH.
- THAT'S A START.
YOU GOTTA HAVE
YOUR OWN STYLE.
WHAT LOOKS BEST ON YOU?
WHAT MAKES YOU
FEEL THE SEXIEST?
- HAVING SEX OUTSIDE.
- OKAY.
WELL, FOR ME AS FAR
AS UPSTAIRS, GOATEE.
AS FAR AS DOWNSTAIRS,
GOATEE, BRO.
- MY PUBES ARE SHAVED
INTO GARGOYLE WINGS.
[phone vibrates]
- GUYS, HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MEET
YOUR FIRST TWO CLIENTS
TONIGHT?
- SAGE, WHAT COULD WE EVER DO
TO VERY MUCH REPAYS YOU?
- OH, DON'T SWEAT IT.
HAVE FUN,
YOU YOUNG [bleep] MACHINES.
[both laugh]
BUT IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PAY ME BACK--
YOU GUYS DON'T HAPPEN
TO HAVE, LIKE,
A SHOWER I COULD USE
LATER TONIGHT, DO YOU?
OR MAYBE A PLACE I COULD
TAKE A NAP INSIDE?
- OKAY, VERY MUCH
WEIRD TURN HERE.
- I'LL JERK YOU BOTH OFF.
- ♪ GET READY TO GO
♪
- NO OFFENSE, NONE TAKEN.
- ♪ READY TO GO